American rapper ASAP Rocky has been in
jail in Sweden for two weeks this
morning a Swedish prosecutor prosecutor
rather wants to keep him in custody for
another week and some US lawmakers are
demanding Rocky's release calling it a
human rights issue
rocky was arrested for alleged
involvement in a street fight in
Stockholm last month which was caught on
video so you're looking at Seoul why do
there yeah he says that one of these
guys was following him he tried to get
away but that they wouldn't leave him
alone and that's what the altercation
was all about these four lawmakers held
a press conference they say that the
conditions that he's being held in are
inhumane the question of course Sweden
is not known for having inhuman prisons
in fact I dug up this nugget in 2005
Saddam Hussein while he was awaiting
trial asked to be transferred to a
prison in Sweden oh wow because because
it was not known to be a very difficult
stay of course the Swedes rejected that
so we'll see what happens there